you know today I go I first of all I
should say that I have my I have my son
and his family visiting from London so I
have two additional little grandchildren
I have one son Mark who lives here and
he has three kids and my son Eric who
lives in London has two kids and they're
visiting so it's pretty hectic even got
my brother from Toronto coming to visit
next week so we're gonna be pretty busy
here but I did want to make a video
because there's been an interesting sort
of exchange on my youtube channel a
person who calls himself cheeky
something rather commented on video that
had quite a while ago where I talked
about the future of the iPad and mobile
devices when it comes to language
learning I think they are phenomenal and
I sort of compared them to the old
tablet that the clay tablet that the
Roman schoolchildren would carry around
and of course the the iPad and it
doesn't have to be the iPad it can be
any of these electronic tablets they
enable you to read they enable you to
look up words that you don't know you
can store tremendous amount of text and
audio and even video there you can
communicate via Skype with native
speakers you can review flashcards I
mean there's so many things that you can
do on these mobile devices I use my iPad
regularly because I prefer to on link to
create my links at the computer but I
don't read then and then I go off and I
can read in the comfort of sitting in my
living room on my iPad I can set my iPad
up on my elliptical trainer you know so
I'm exercising and I have downloaded the
audio which is running on my mp3 player
so I'm listening to it I couldn't do it
through the iPod but I just don't it's
more convenient for me to have it going
in the background I'm jogging I'm
reading with my finger I'm poking at
words that I don't know they pop up and
so I can keep up and I'm listening to
the text that I do that for 25
and is a tremendous exercise of
interacting with the language and I'm
sure that there will be more and more
applications developed for iPhone iPad
or Android or whatever which to me is
quite revolutionary so someone came on
and said that these iPads are a
distraction that essentially you have to
have that face-to-face interaction
between the teacher and the learner in
order for learning to take place and so
we've had quite a lively exchange and so
I guess the question comes up you know
what is the future role of a classroom
or a teacher insofar as language
learning is concerned so let me say that
you know I have often said that I
believe that massive input is almost a
precondition for being able to learn
grammar that without this exposure to
the language the grammar explanations
don't stick I've said that it's very
difficult and I'm this is based on my
experience as a learner and watching
other people learn it's very difficult
to learn these rules and study some a
few words and try and put them together
because all of these grammar concepts
take a long time to sink in and it
requires a lot of exposure and
experience with the language before
these explanations start to make sense
and start to stick and therefore my
preference is to focus on listening and
reading vocabulary accumulation so that
I have a more solid base in
comprehension so that I can understand
the language I don't worry about
speaking for six months per year
depending on the language and I find
that when I start to speak or if I have
a need to speak the bigger my vocabulary
the more familiar I am with the language
the better I understand what I hear the
better I do so then what is the rule of
the class what is the role of the
classroom well the role of the classroom
is not going to go away because most
people aren't motivated enough to learn
on their own most people believe that
they can only learn in the classroom so
the idea that there are all these
resources available on the Internet is
relatively new I find that the
explanations of
I can find them all over the internet so
I don't have to sit in the classroom and
hope that the issue that I have
difficulty with is the one that the
teacher is gonna focus on that day I can
zoom in on those issues that I'm
interested in so however now I want to
backtrack and say that add link I would
say that the best tutors are people who
are professional teachers teachers okay
that's whether it be you know if Jenny
and in in st. Petersburg but it would be
Reinhard in Vienna and I'm not gonna
name everybody but you know even in
Sofia you know and I deal with I deal
with a lot of tutors and so that's the
second issue I need tutors once I have
spent enough time with the language be
at six months or more then I need to
talk to tutors I need the tutors to
point out my mistakes I have to
sometimes ask them questions what also
happens in the case of link you have
tutors who create content about
different issues of grammar and put them
in our library so we can review them
over and over again we can listen to
them in the target language whether it
be various content in German or evgeny's
in Russian or whomever I can listen to
it over and over again so I'm listening
and reading and also focusing on those
grammar issues that I'm ready to focus
on that I want to focus on so the role
of the teacher remains important the
role of the teacher first of all as a
stimulus because if I know that I'm
going to be talking to my tutor it kind
of keeps me going I want to show my
tutor that I'm improving the tutor is
very often a source of encouragement a
source of stimulus but it's not so much
a matter of explaining things that's the
thing that the teacher as explainer I
just don't see that as such an important
role because the third theoretical
explanation is not gonna do it you have
to see the patterns over and over again
refer over and over again perhaps to
some grammar rules where the learner has
the initiative and so in our exchange of
course with this person on the
you know the iPad and language learning
or something like that in fact I might
put a link to that particular video I
mean he was on and on about how if you
don't cover the classroom you can learn
because it's very difficult because
there's five different future tenses I
mean yeah you can make the language
sound as complicated as you want I don't
think anyone can absorb five future
tenses at one city but if a learner
hasn't had enough exposure to the
language bit by bit
by reviewing certain grammar rules
either on their own or by having their
writing or their conversational language
corrected they'll start to notice these
things more and more so many people tell
me at length that they have learned much
more with us than they have in a more
traditional classroom setting that's not
to condemn the teacher I think there are
lots of excellent teachers but in a
classroom with fifteen or twenty other
students the teacher decides the agenda
and I think that the learner needs to
decide the agenda and the learner needs
to control their learning and I suspect
that what's going to happen is that what
we are doing at Linc
oh and of course the other thing that
people like to criticize me for is that
I'm just out promoting and pushing you
know this product that I'm selling and
stuff like that of course I'm promoting
link but why did I create link in the
first place because I think is helpful
to language learning now of course we
have a lot of cost that makes the work
obviously interested in encouraging
people to come and use it and the more
people who come and use it the more we
can invest in making it better that's no
different than the commercial interests
that a teacher has or an ESL school has
in promoting their form of language
instruction services it's a saint and we
are ultimately what matters the most is
where is the best return on investment
for the language learner in other words
is the language learner better off going
to an ESL school say the person wants to
learn English say jump on a flat plane
from Japan or
fly to Vancouver enroll in an ESL school
that's $1200 a month and stay in a
homestay and do all of these things is
that a good return on investment
ultimately that's what's going to matter
and that the market will decide that I
think that it's not ideal I think that a
smaller number of instructional hours a
smaller number of hours of interaction
three hours a week five hours a week
would be very heavy in my opinion one
two three hours a week with a tutor
either online or face-to-face and then
some encouragement from the tutor or
some explanation on how to learn
directing the tutor to where is a
learner rather to where they can find
excellent resources that's a better use
of the teachers time better return on
investment for the learner and it would
enable teachers to reach many many more
people in the case of Canada
I mean immigrants apparently we spend
$3,000 per head per year on immigrant
language training and a recent study out
of Toronto showed that at least amongst
the Chinese speaking immigrants who are
the largest source country in Canada
after seven years a group of 3,000 of
these immigrants were followed and they
were enrolled in language programs here
and they made essentially no progress no
progress the sort of another group the
Slavic speakers did make progress and
the reason to make progress is because
they were more likely to make friends
with Canadians interact more with
Canadians take a greater interest in the
local culture in other words what
mattered the most was what they did
outside the classroom not what they did
inside the classroom so that being the
case why spend three thousand dollars a
year per immigrant or twelve hundred
dollars a month for these ESL programs
when there are more cost-effective ways
that you can utilize teacher resources
and after all it's only a small
percentage of immigrants that are helped
through these language programs many
more are unable to get into these
programs so why wouldn't we devise a
more efficient way to enable teachers to
help learners or to encourage learners
to hell
to learn on their own and I think in
that regard the iPad iPhone other mobile
devices Android art and the Internet and
all the resources that are on the
Internet are revolutionary and they have
changed the paradigm and so to continue
to insist that language instruction can
only take place in the classroom as this
Tiki whatever is doing he alternates
between that and you know getting vulgar
and insulting me you know to me that's I
understand the guy he wants to protect
his job that's fine plus that's perhaps
all he knows but the reality is that
that there are so many other resources
available today that didn't exist ten
even ten years ago let alone 50 years
ago so there you have it I thought I
would just you know and he's welcome to
make a video and post it here as a
response I haven't deleted any of this
even though they're everything kind of a
bit nasty I haven't deleted any of his
comments yeah I think free exchange of
ideas and it's not and I repeat this
it's not an T teacher I think there are
while there are some teachers who are
protectionist of their position and
closed-minded I know a lot of teachers
who are looking for new resources
looking for ways to do their job better
who want to help more people some of
them are members of link some of them
are the best tutors that we have but I
think that and I also recognize that in
a you know public school environment a
large number of students are not very
motivated and therefore the teacher's
job really is to push the curriculum at
them and force them to take tests and
hope that most of the past and of course
if we look at the results in Canada even
where many do pass say they're French
very few of them learn how to speak the
language so there is something
fundamentally wrong with what we're
doing in the way languages are taught in
the school system and I think to
basically dismiss the iPad and mobile
devices is some kind of a distraction
you know promoted by the crass
commercialism of Apple and examples of
this sort of out-of-control consumerism
in the modern world it's not like that
to me it defeats the purpose the issue
is can they be
effectively to augment and to you know
what is done by the teacher to empower
the learner to empower the teacher I
think the answer is yes so there you
have it thank you for listening